[Music]
so you define yourself as a skeptic or
you're one of the enjoying the skeptics
camp how do you define that and what
does it mean for the way you live your
day-to-day life
so skepticism means different things at
different people
it started out actually as a philosophy
of life back in ancient Greece and the
skeptics the ancient skeptics thought
that the way to get a good luck to live
a good life was simply to suspend
judgment now to attach yourself to any
opinion that way I imagine that if you
actually can manage that you have no
political opinions and buddy nobody's
gonna be after you because you're on the
right or the left or the center and
whatever so they thought that this was
the way to to have peace of mind in life
and since they also argued that there
really is no way for human beings to
know and anything for sure then it was a
interesting coherent philosophy modern
skepticism means something different it
is very much related with - due to the
reactions against pseudoscience it is
very much a movement in support of
scientific education so a modern skeptic
would be somebody who ideally at least
investigates phenomena that are outside
of the normal preview of science you
know UFOs astrology parapsychology
things like that things that scientists
themselves probably won't be bothered to
do
and with the intention to figure out if
there is in fact anything behind these
things I prefer to think of modern
sceptics as you know people who are
generally open-minded about the
possibility of paranormal or strange
phenomena but that really want to see
the evidence and seriously look at what
the claims are and and whether they
stand up to scrutiny usually they don't
that's the problem so ie
a modern skeptic or an ancient skeptic
I'm a modern skeptic my philosophy of
life is leans more towards tourism than
then skepticism in terms of ancient
philosophies I do think the ancient
story at the ancient skeptics were
interesting Bunch and they had a number
of interesting points they do inform
mordants skepticism because we do retain
this notion that knowledge proof is a
very high standard that almost the
Islamic almost never reached in reality
even in science you know when people say
oh there's a scientific proof of
something well usually scientists don't
prove things mathematicians are more in
the business are proving scientists can
provide evidence but evidence can be
faulty evidence can be a provisional
scientific theories may may be supported
up to a certain point and then abandoned
so the modern view of human knowledge is
in a sense more skeptical that is we
really are aware of the limitations even
of science so as a modern skeptic and
when you looked at certain
ideas that are maybe not mainstream
scientific ideas more kind of paranormal
beliefs oh and reflections on those kind
of experiences was there you said most
of them don't stand up to scrutiny but
whether any that did that's a good
question
historically yes like it depends on how
you look at things but for instance
alchemy is today it's considered
pseudoscience because if you think that
you can actually turn you know light
into gold or something like that you're
seriously mistaken but at some point in
the past alchemy was could they take it
seriously until a few centuries ago well
then he mutated in a sense into what we
today call modern chemistry right so the
alchemist the successful alchemists
became chemists and chemistry certainly
science so that kind of claim stood up
the alchemists actually did discover
things about what we were to take all
the chemistry of elements although their
core idea was in fact mistaken so there
are examples in the history of science
where certain fields start out in a kind
of a sketchy position and then they
either evolve into pseudoscience they
develop I should say or they evolve into
science and we think about it the other
obvious example is the fact that until
several centuries ago there was no sharp
distinction between astronomy and
astrology there is today but you know
Ptolemy and was just as much an
astronomer as an astrologer and that
went on for most of the Middle Ages and
then only gradually people realize that
there was some good stuff to keep that's
what we today call astronomy and some
stuff that didn't work out and that's
what we think of astrology even very
famous scientists got involved at some
point or another we what we would today
call pseudoscience I mean Newton is
arguably one of the most you know famous
and you know the geniuses of science of
all time
turns out he spent more time studying
alchemy and doing biblical credit
of all things than physics but we
remember today as a physicist because
the physical part worked and the alchemy
and biblical criticism dinner more so
are there any contemporary examples from
contemporary science that you think is
more pseudoscience or in slightly
problematic there's a number of areas of
modern science that are problematic but
that's the nature of science I think so
for instance of the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence our safety
yeah it's done by scientists is done by
using very expensive instrumentation in
radio telescopes usually it's definitely
not a pseudoscience but it's not quite
science is it we don't know we have no
data at all you know we're in found a
single case so far so the sample size is
n equals zero the theory is a little bit
shaky and optimistic and basically you
said the researchers simply assumed that
there are beings out there that have a
similar psychology to our own and want
to communicate with us so it's it's a
little bit you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't consider it a mainstream
science it's kind of one of those
borderline cases evolutionary psychology
is another one so the notion that human
behavior evolved is pretty sound that's
part of standard evolutionary biology
but when you try to apply directly
evolutionary theory to modern human
behaviors are such as gender differences
for instance and then becomes much more
problematic because it's difficult to do
the appropriate tests it's data are
difficult to gather it's easy to
speculate and to come up with I thought
this is that however are not necessarily
standing up to scrutiny so psychology is
another one of those things is right in
between and depending on future
development over the next decade or so
we may talk about it as an established
science down the line or as something
that actually devolved into
pseudoscience
in less recent but not too distant past
things like eugenics or phrenology both
of those were considered scientific when
they had their heyday and then
eventually you know both of them were
sort of dismissed as not working and
from a scientific perspective and if
people insist in in pushing them then
that's when the word pseudoscience comes
up pseudoscience doesn't refer to
something that is wrong to an idea that
it's wrong because there's plenty of
ideas in science that turn out to be
wrong like what I would like every
theory in physics before the current one
and probably the current one is is also
at least incomplete so in some sense is
wrong current one I mean quantum
mechanics which at the moment is the
most established scientific idea of all
times but physicists already know that
it's incomplete so there that's why
they're searching for the next iteration
so the difference between science and
pseudoscience doesn't lie in the fact
that one is right in the other one is
wrong that's actually a common
misconception both in the public in
general and sometimes even among
skeptics the real difference is in the
methods and the real difference is in
the fact that once you are you get a
negative result you accept it you say
well okay that didn't work so we're
gonna set it aside if there are negative
results showing very clearly and
consistently that an idea didn't work
and yet the proponents of that idea
insist that it is a good one that's when
they begin to slide into pseudoscience
I mean pseudo-scientists they don't use
that term but pseudo scientists have the
same trappings of science they published
journals they have conferences you know
they look at empirical evidence
sometimes they do statistical analysis
so from the outside - a person doesn't
know better they it looks like they're
doing science but if you're doing that
kind of things with a notion that it's
been clearly discredited then that to me
is that arguably the best definition of
pseudoscience
so how far as a skeptic modern skeptic
how far can you actually embrace the
idea that okay we have not knowledge of
for instance when that this is the way
quantum mechanics work or like or do you
always kind of have kind of critical
doubt it might not exactly be their way
yeah if you're a good sense that you
should always have a really cool bit in
mine you're critical little thing in the
back on your mind even with
well-established scientific theories I
mean philosophers of science have come
up with this notion called the
pessimistic meta induction which sounds
really complicated but in fact it's a
simple idea inductive reasoning is a
type of reasoning that we do all the
time it's when you generalize from
certain instances that you know of to a
more general situation right so so if I
add a static align is based on induction
for instance if I want to know the
average height of population in a town
I'm not going to measure every single
inhabitant what I'm gonna do is gonna
take a sample and then I generalize from
that sample that's induction now if you
do that with the history of science it
turns out that every single scientific
theory that's been proposed up to this
point now to be wrong so if you apply
induction you will conclude that even
current scientific theories will turn
out eventually to be wrong it's called a
pessimistic induction because it
basically leads you to believe that
science it's always wrong but there are
degrees of wrongness right so Newtonian
mechanics is more wrong than general
relativity general relativity also is
wrong or incomplete because there are
certain things that just don't work out
very well with in theory so we know
physicists know this and they're looking
again for the next iteration just like
there they are for quantum mechanics but
to say that to simply stop and say that
both general relativity and Newtonian
mechanics were wrong it's not quite the
full story because Ron doesn't come in
to only two categories there's a degrees
of wrongness
okay so this Udo science is the most
wrong and then kind of general
relativity and quantum mechanics
slightly less wrong than that there
there are a lot more than slightly less
right but yeah but it the general notion
is correct there is a continuum right so
at one extreme you have things like
astrology alchemy or things like that
things that we know by now are incorrect
notions there are still people believe
them that's that's a different issue but
pretty much we figured it out I would be
stunned in if it turned out that all of
a sudden astrology in fact turned out to
be correct we have plenty of empirical
evidence and planning very good
theoretical reasons to think that as
George is not working so that's one
extreme at the opposite extreme you have
very very well-established scientific
theories such as quantum mechanics
general relativity the theory of
evolution in biology
now those also are at least incomplete
which means that technically they're
wrong but but they're really the
opposite extreme of that continue and
then in the middle there is all these
other stuff that it's difficult to tell
such as fields like parapsychology or
evolutionary psychology or Sadie some of
these are a little bit more on the
scientific side of the divide some of
them are more on the pseudo scientific
but it's like the jury's still out
I wouldn't for instance you know I would
bet much more money against astrology
than against parapsychology I was still
better significant amount of money
against parapsychology but not as much
as I'm you know so so if you think of
the amount of money that you weren't
into bad as the degree of confidence
that you have that something is either
going to work or not going to work then
I would put a lot of money on the
validity of quantum mechanics and a lot
of money on the invalidity of astrology
but if you're picking something in
between I'm gonna keep my money and see
what happens okay moving on to stoic
says
how did you turn towards this philosophy
as a kind of philosophy for life midlife
crisis which I'm told pretty much
everybody goes through at some point or
another I was appearing in life where
things were going not too well
personally and and even from the point
of view of my profession it it seemed
like I had hit a little bit of a quiet
zone where yeah I was doing my job and
was doing fine but it wasn't anything it
was particularly novel or exciting or
something like that so those are the
period in life for you sir if you can
afford it you can stop and think about
stuff and saying hmm what am I gonna go
from there now since I was beginning to
study philosophy professionally because
at the up adèle up until that time
I was actually a professional biologist
I switched to philosophy and about that
time once you start studying philosophy
at the graduate level in that in my case
but even I think at pretty much any
level you can't avoid start thinking
about sort of the big picture and then
saying you know you read played all for
instance or you read a book on ethics or
something oh that's interesting where do
I fit in with this so that kind of
started a quest to explore different
possible options and I looked at in a
number of possible philosophies of life
the philosophy of life by the way it's
nothing mysterious it's just a
combination of two things
a metaphysics and an ethics a
metaphysics is a base essentially an
account of how the world works and
ethics is an account of how you should
behave in the world if you define it
that way then every religion is also a
philosophy of life right so I grew up
Catholic for instance and you know
Catholicism is gives you metaphysics it
tells you that the world was originally
by a God and the God decides what goes
on in the world that's a metaphysics and
then it tells you you know an ethics it
tells you you go to church on Sundays
because you want to learn how to be a be
a better person right so those two
characteristics are common between you
know among all religions and
philosophies of life so I looked at a
number of them explored them including
Buddhism
including a two or three different
ancient Greek Roman philosophies and I
was in the middle of this thing and then
one day on Twitter of all places I saw
this thing that said help us celebrate
stoic week I said what the hell is stoic
week and why wouldn't anyone want to
celebrate it
I remember the Stoics from from high
school but I didn't really remember much
about them other than they're supposed
to suppress emotions and go through life
with a stiff upper lip which turned out
not to be true those are both arrow
types but hey that's what I remember but
I was curious so I signed up turns out
that stoic Week is an annual event which
happens every fall is organized by an
international group of scholars
philosophers historians and currently
behavioral therapists because it turns
out that stories must actually has
influenced the development of CBT in the
1950s and 60s so there are certain kinds
of psychotherapy that actually
originally at least where inspiration
from the from the Stoics so I did it for
a week it really clicked it's in like I
say reading the historic sand I started
practicing you know their meditations
and their exercises and really collected
so I committed for another couple of
months until the end of the year and
then I committed for another year and
then here we are five years later I
wrote two books about it what's one of
your dearest
you know rules already historic ideas
that have really helped you the
fundamental one that has made a major
difference in my life and it does affect
the life of pretty much anybody who
practices tourism it's something called
the dichotomy of control
the Stoics believe that everything you
do can be partitioned in two components
one part that is really up to you where
you really have control and another part
that you then it's not up to you what
you don't have control because or
complete control because the outcome
depends on external factors and a
fundamental tenet of stoic philosophy is
that you should focus all your energy on
the part that is under your control and
then develop an attitude of equanimity
toward the second component sometimes
you win sometimes you don't but it's not
a reflection of who you are it's a
reflection of the fact that the universe
works in you know strange ways so let me
give you a specific example let's say
that that tomorrow you're up for a job
interview and you know the normal thing
to do would be to to be anxious and say
you know I really want this job and I am
really gonna help then I get it and so
on that's normal the stoic would
approach in this way like well tomorrow
I have a job interview did I do
everything in my power up to this point
to prepare for the interview yes and my
focus for at the beginning of the
interview yes do I know what I'm talking
about yes that's it done then how the
interview goes it's not really up to you
it depends on your competition it
depends on who the interviewer is you
know whatever whether he got up in the
morning and went on a strange mood or
whatever and the fact that even if you
get the job you shouldn't according to
the Stoics you shouldn't feel too cocky
because part of it is a result of your
efforts but part of it is you just got
lucky
and similarly however if you fail if you
don't get the interview you shouldn't
beat yourself up because again it's not
under your control you did if you did
what everything you could
that's that's all that's all that it's
under your control so that really does
help I think that essentially it in
modern terms is the the basic notion is
to internalize your goals so I just
mentioned the job interview let's say
that you know a common thought is if
general relationship I hope she loves me
know I hope to be a loving person
because that's under your control but if
she loves you back it's up to her oh I
hope that this friend is gonna you know
really be a good friend well you can be
a good friend that's I'm under your
control whether other people are gonna
be difference to you or not it's not and
so on and so forth so you can apply it
pretty much everywhere and once you
start practicing that way and thing
looking at things that way you just calm
down
because you say well I'm gonna accept
whatever happens so long as I know that
I've done the best that I could two
final questions so does that mean that
basically I have a continuous dialogue
in your head so one voice is the kind of
anxious irrational voice saying oh my
god but I really want this interview and
then the stoic within you says you've
done everything you could is that what
happened that's pretty much it that's
right and in fact that's also a
technique that he's using in County
behavioral therapy to challenge your own
thoughts challenge your own perceptions
Epictetus was one of the major historic
philosophers from the second century and
he has this beautiful way of expressing
these thoughts he said that we should
look at our impressions and impression
in stoic terminology is your initial
opinion about something so for instance
that oh my gosh should I have the
interview and this is stressful this is
a stressful story that's Annie that's an
opinion that that's expressing an
opinion
or who
is expressing the opinion the interview
is just a fact of life it's not the
interview doesn't come with opinions you
are expressing their opinion and so you
can challenge yourself and say wait a
minute why am I thinking this way why
why not try to think about things in a
different way and that actually does
work there's pretty good empirical
evidence that you you know it's not a
silver bullet so it's not like you start
doing this tonight and all of a sudden
your life is fine but if you're doing a
regular basis you learn to challenge
your own impressions your own opinion
your own judgments then little by little
you it will become easier and easier and
at some point you stop having those kind
of distressing that's where the
stereotype of the lack of emotion comes
from it's not a question of suppressing
emotions it's it's a question of
controlling and interacting with your
negative thoughts great I was gonna ask
you as a final question about whether
there is a stoic philosopher that you
hold particularly dare and I just
mentioned it but you've just hopped a
button epictetus I think someone else as
well no I think it is good good I mean
the the guy had was an incredible person
he started out his life as a slave and
then he was freed started studying stoic
philosophy became the most famous
philosopher and teacher in in 2nd
century Rome he had an incredible sense
of humor and he had it was blunt movie
students just tall the thing as he saw
so one for instance one of my favorite
quotes from Epictetus says so I have to
die well one of these days I'll have to
die apparently this is not the day but
now I'm hungry so I'm gonna go and take
lunch because that's under my control
and then when Ben comes you know we'll
deal with it at that point for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you